bienvenue au parlement européen à
bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo émission spéciale consacrée
à la crise des migrants et l'europe qui
muscle sa politique adieu frontex et
vive la garde frontalière européenne
dix-huit mois après un afflux massif de
réfugiés et de migrants depuis la mer
egée l'europe et les pays de l'espace
schengen lance une agence de garde
frontières et de gardes côtes
cette fois directement sous commandement
européen puis à direction l'allemagne à
berlin
comment les allemands accueille le
réfugiés syriens souvent jeunes plus tôt
il y a les villes comme une classe
traduction des classes bienvenue des
classes pour aider les jeunes migrants à
s'intégrer en un an mil classe de
bienvenue ont été ouvertes pour douze
mille élèves en tout apparaît immense en
période d'austérité on en débat tout de
suite avec nos invités les eurodéputés
evelyne gebhardt et nathalie griesbeck
ainsi que jean quatremer le
correspondant de libération à bruxelles
c'est une avancée remarquable par ces
temps de doute européen
l'union est depuis une semaine doter
d'un véritable corps de garde côtes et
de garde-frontières commun qui aura le
pouvoir et les moyens d'assurer la
surveillance de ses frontières
extérieures au regarde et on réagit
juste après frontex et fassent vivre
lagarde frontalière européenne un an
après l'afflux massif de demandeurs
d'asile sur le vieux continent
un nouveau corps de gardes frontières
entre en service afin d'épauler frontex
le bras armé des politiques migratoires
mission mieux protéger les frontières de
l'union européenne et offrir une image
d'unité sur la question complexe
migratoire l' agence européenne des
gardes frontières et des garde côtes
aura les mêmes missions que frontex
patrouiller dans le ciel de la
méditerranée venir au secours des
migrants ou encore gérer les hotspots
ces centres de rétention aux frontières
de l'union
mais la nouvelle police des frontières
se veut plus ambitieuse depuis la
bulgarie le commissaire chargée des
migrations a tenu à annoncer
officiellement la création de cette
nouvelle agence à compter de ce jour la
frontière extérieure de l'un de nos
états membres est la frontière
extérieure de tous nos états notre
position est très claire
la porte est ouverte en europe pour ceux
qui ont besoin d'une protection
internationale
elle est fermée pour ceux qui veulent
venir chez nous il également plus
ambitieux cette nouvelle agence de 400
agents pour frontex ses effectifs
devraient passer à 2500 le budget est
aussi en hausse
250 millions d'euros près du double de
celui d'aujourd'hui
cette agence des gardes-frontières et
des garde-côtes sera directement sous
commandement européen
là où frontex se contentait de
coordonner l'action des différentes
police aux frontières de chaque pays
la nouvelle entité sera indépendante des
états
lagence européenne vient renforcer les
moyens nationaux elle ne les remplace
pas tous les membres de l'union
européenne devront fournir des
détachements l'un des objectifs
principaux sera de prêter main forte à
la police grecque
pour éviter qu'elle soit à nouveau
débordé par l'afflux de réfugiés
voilà nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
evelyne gebhardt bonjour vous êtes
députée allemande du groupe socialiste
et démocrate
ça vous nathalie griesbeck bonjour vous
êtes eurodéputée française de l'alliance
des démocrates et libéraux pour l'europe
en france vous avez été élu sous les
couleurs du modem à côté de vous jean
quatremer merci nous avoir rejoints vous
couvrir l'actualité européenne pour
libération depuis 26 ans vous êtes plus
tout jeune je signe à ça je signale
votre je suis bien de votre blog
coulisses de bruxelles où tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à l'europe alors une
agence européenne des gardes frontières
et des garde-côtes
est ce que cette avancée elle va régler
à elle seule la crise migratoire
yvelines gamme à papa c'est évident mais
je pense que c'est un pas en avant qui
est très important et qui montre qu'on
est quand même capable dans l'europe
d'avoir une certaine forme de solidarité
en mettant en commun les forces qui sont
nécessaires et je crois que ça c'est une
bonne avancée et s'il nos états membres
continuent sur cette route là alors nous
finirons pas trouvé quand même des
solutions viables pour les problèmes que
nous avons aujourd'hui nathalie
griesbeck c'est quand même historique à
l agence pourra intervenir sur décision
du conseil européen sur les frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne dans
un état membre même s'il en fait pas la
demande
moi je me réjouis pas hésité à porter
sur ce projet pour pour ses gardes
frontières pour mon groupe parlementaire
et je me réjouis parce que c'est une
avancée européenne
ça a été dit dans la présentation il
s'agit pas d'un d'un regroupement de
deux décisions des différents états mais
d'une vraie étape européenne avec des
moyens qui sont renforcés pour l'instant
1000 à 1500 personnes pour protéger les
frontières externes mais surtout des
pouvoirs renforcés à l' agence dirigée
d'ailleurs avec avec beaucoup de force
par fabrice l'égérie et
c'est aussi pour moi c'est pour ça que
c'est je pense que c'est vraiment une
étape européenne
c'est aussi un moyen de préserver la
liberté de circulation préserver
schengen c'est à dire l'aqiii
fondamentales de l'union européenne en
organisant notre protection aux
frontières externes et si je peux
ajouter le d'abord le texte a été assez
vite
c'est remarquable en europe en moins
d'un an ça a été posée en décembre et à
la fin juin s'était terminée voter c'est
quand même extraordinaire on est on est
28e gala membres n'est 28 et avant
contexte et elle est belle aussi
oui mais il ya beaucoup de contexte
exceptionnel vous me l'accorderez où on
est dans l'inertie où on est tous
pétrifiés au lieu d'agir là les faits
les choses ont été vite et des moyens
renforcés en particulier aussi de
sauvetage en mer d'organisation
d'enregistrement et d'intervention
possibles d'une manière européenne sur
des états qui auraient un flux massif ne
ferait chien jean 80 ça veut dire que
des gardes-frontière allemand espagnol
polonais et peuvent intervenir au nom de
l'union européenne en grèce en italie
même si la grèce et l'italie ne veulent
pas exactement s'ils veulent pas comment
ça se passe
s'ils veulent pas ils devront
c'est-à-dire recevoir c'est ses
gardes-frontières donc on les oblige me
sèye c'est un peu comme le sait le vote
à la majorité qualifiée au sein de
l'union européenne comment ça se passe
la présente la france ne veut pas d'une
directive sur les droits d'auteur et le
vôtre contre il ya une majorité
qualifiée qui votent pour elle applique
le texte eh bien c'est la même chose
mais là c'est énorme c'est un pas
fédéral comme on en connaît un conflit
où l'on accomplit assez peu le précédent
c'est une union bancaire il a fallu une
crise d'une gravité extrême et dont on
n'est pas encore sorti pour qu'enfin
fédéralise le contrôle des banques
le la précédente c'était la monnaie
unique
il faut se rendre compte que la ligue
comme on a fait schengen en 95 les états
donc ont supprimé contrôles aux
frontières intérieures et donc les
frontières extérieures devenue un bien
commun mais chacun a voulu garder chaque
pays a voulu garder le contrôle de sa
frontière extérieure
honnêtement dès le départ et moi j'avais
suivi les négociations du de schengen
dès 1985
on savait très bien
que les grecs ou les italiens n'étaient
pas capables de garder de sauvegarder
leurs frontières
on le savait mais bon ça inclut pendant
15 ans et il a fallu ces crises
migratoires ou d'un seul coup
effectivement on s'est aperçu quand des
millions de personnes arrivées des
centaines de milliers voire des millions
de personnes sont arrivées
qu'effectivement la grèce qui a
plusieurs milliers d'îles est incapable
de contrôler ses frontières que les
italiens sont désorganisés et n'arrive
pas à contrôler les frontières le seul
pays qui a réussi à peu près à contrôler
ses frontières et qui a joué le jeu
c'est l'espagne parce que dans les
années 95 on a oublié que l'espagne
était confronté à ce qu'on appelait des
pâtés race donc vous aviez des milliers
de clandestins venant du maroc qui
passaient et le maroc le l'espagne a
réussi à s'entendre avec le maroc pour
bloquer les clandestins au maroc donc la
face à cet afflux
on n'a pas eu d'autre choix que de
partager je dirais cette souveraineté du
contrôle aux frontières extérieures
mais encore une fois c'est pas la
panacée c'est très peu de personnes 2500
le à l'avenir moi je pense la seule
façon de s'en sortir c'est
confédéraliste totalement nos forces de
garde-frontières et de garde-côtes
on n'a pas d'autre choix qu'une
généralisation totale alors ya l'autre
volet du plan
juncker et le président la commission
pour faire face à cette crise l'autre
volet il est un peu en panne
la solidarité européenne dans la
répartition des des réfugiés déjà arrivé
au sol européen
cette solidarité s'est un peu effondré
les relocalisations sont au point mort
horrible il ya ba ba oui nous avons
certains états membres qui n'acceptent
pas ce qui est la démocratie des votes
en majorité qualifiée est la hongrie la
pologne la tchéquie et d'autres dié ont
décidé bon ça a été votée mais on ne le
fait pas et ça c'est absolument
inacceptable je pense qu'il est temps
grand temps même des référendums même si
serena qui a foiré bien florea il faut
boire valable et donc croire et parce
qu'il n'y avait pas eu le quorum mais
95% des bruits avant cinq ans de vivre
mende et dont le sort est à 56 5 % des
citoyens de la hongrie qui n'ont pas
voté on ne peut pas se dire qu'ils sont
tous delà du même avis que ceux qui ont
voté donc je dirais il ya des règles
dans les états membres
il ya des corps hommes qui n'ont pas été
acceptées et donc
ça a foiré oui on peut on ne peut pas
dire comme le 6e au ban
écoutez nous augmentons le quorum parce
que c'est lui qui l'a augmenté de 25 à
50% participation de participation au
vote
et ça fallait au moins 50% entre fallu
on voit là et ça n'a pas fonctionné il
dit bon ben tant pis ça ne ça n'a pas
fonctionné sahel m de fond problème de
fond mais l'échec de dublin
oui c'est un échec total absolu à une
absence de réel je la dessine pour le
spectateur que dublin en fait c'est que
ça prévoit que le premier pays d'entrée
rien gérer la demande d'asile doit gérer
le magazine donc en l'occurrence la
grèce l'italie ou l'espagne sur les
pays-bas et les pays de la ligne de
front djoghlaf ces réfugiés mais on n'a
pas accepté on a laissé dublin par
définition elle a su si bien si on donne
on a on n'a pas respecté respecté du
glace c'est vrai mais on ne pouvait pas
laisser les gens eux seuls aux
frontières intérieures et dire ben
écoutez vous mourrez de faim c'est tant
pis ça nous ça nous ne veulent pas on va
nova et l'allemagne m l'allemagne a été
exemplaire
elle a été la plus européenne la plus
conforme au respect des traités on veut
pas dire l'allemagne n'a pas respecté la
rue blanche il faut faire
bon je suis allé dans des camps de
réfugiés je suis allé à ceuta et mellila
pour voir comment en espagne les choses
s'étaient organisés je suis allé dans
des camps en bavière tuer les halles à
plusieurs reprises à la frontière
syrienne où libon etc
je suis allé sur le pire des cas que
j'ai vu j'ai un peu honte de le dire
c'est le dernier camp que j'ai vue à
calais avec une situation absolument
abominable pour tout le monde et
spécialement pour les mineurs non
accompagnés
spécialement pour eux il ya près de 1000
enfants vulnérables par définition ne
sont pas pris en charge et en allemagne
pour revenir au débat en allemagne
écoutez moi chapeau à la chancelière qui
aujourd'hui paix parce que justement
quand je ne fais sur le plan électoral
s'est retourné s'est aperçu aucun des
autres pays exerçait une formule et
lundi vers les goûts des gens comme elle
l'était vous étiez les salles nathalie
griesbeck mois le problème c'est que je
suis comme vous je j'approuve ce qu'a
fait la chancelière et j'aurai davantage
pu défendre ce qu'ils la chancelière si
elle avait eu penser juste a décroché
son téléphone à dire à ses petits
camarades
ça serait quand même je vais faire ça je
vous le signale on a suffisamment
l'enchère est d'un or vous aideront à
mener on a suffisamment reproché à la
france ses décisions unilatérales en
matière d'action extérieure pour ne pas
dire que là quand même un sujet qui
concerne l ensemble des européens jeudi
qu'elle aurait pu faire convoquer un
conseil européen à bruxelles
ils s'étaient réunis en 24 heures tout
le monde se réunissait et on disait elle
est très jolie
ce succès médiatique de madame merkel
mais là je dois prendre ça moins de
chance parce que dans la situation dans
laquelle nous étions il n'y avait pas le
temps de faire un don de faire un grand
conseil herman européen il s'agissait de
la vie de personnes qu'ils décrochent au
téléphone les français ont découvert ce
sens qu'elle l'a fait elle a dit qu'elle
l'avait fait je ne sais pas je ne le
sais pas combien tous les cas il était
absolument temps de faire quelque chose
on ne pouvait pas dire aux gens
écoutez on va faire une réunion à
bruxelles et puis dans deux semaines ou
trois semaines
vous serez mort mais on aura réglé votre
problème avéré non pas ce n'était pas
posée avait raison qu'il fallait
vraiment il fallait
vous êtes députée allemande qui a motivé
un gala merkel à ouvrir les portes
c'est quoi ces c'est d'en effacer
l'image d'une ancienne allemagne cessé
dans les images c'est dans l'histoire de
l'allemagne se saouler ce sont les mots
comme on dit en français les réfugiés et
les réfugiés
nous avons eu une phase en allemagne au
début du 20e siècle
horrible et nous avons tiré les leçons
de cette histoire 145 en un mois la rue
et nous avons dit plus jamais nous ne
voulant voir cela je veux c'est
justement cet humanisme et son humanisme
sonel a été qui a géré cette situation
et qui a fait en sorte aussi que en gros
la citoyenneté en allemagne elle a été
d'accord avec cela en vaut encore
aujourd'hui juste l'aide de personne
bénévole elle est énorme
ça me rappelle quand même que les
allemands ce n'est pas la première fois
ils ont accueilli 9000 réfugiés de la
guerre en s en neuf cent mille pardons
réfugiés de la guerre en ex yougoslavie
pendant que la france ont accueilli
aucun dire que c'est pas la première
fois et d'ailleurs la plupart de ces
réfugiés
on a accueilli aussi les résultats mieux
là on a été corrects nathalie griesbeck
revanche l'absence de solidarité à la
suite de cette décision qu'a prise
l'allemagne elle a bien fait de pas
attendre le xxi ème sommet qui ne sert à
rien elle a très bien fait en revanche
l'absence de solidarité et je redis
quand elle s'est retournée et qu'elle a
vu quand même à cela nous a amenés dans
un engrenage et là moi je conteste la
décision qu'elle a prise en ce qui
concerne l'accord une turquie
là elle a été seul elle a décidé un peu
seul et cet accord ue turquie pour moi
est totalement mortifère par rapport aux
réfugiés par rapport à la solidarité
je sais pas si vous êtes d'accord autant
elle a été admirable quand elle a décidé
d'avancer pas attendre que les gens ne
meurent pour prendre des décisions
autant après voyons qu'elle était très
isolée elle a pris elle a pris à elle a
pris 1
elle a fait une démarche qui est content
et cela promet un câble alors qu' un
bloc de l'est ce qui qui défie quand
même les valeurs de l'europe si d'après
ce qu'on n'ait pas été un peu trop
rapide dans l'élargissement d'abonnés la
réussite de villepin oui mais je récuse
ce qu'ils sont ils disent les choses
brutalement c'est vrai mais est ce que
la france dans cette affaire halfon la
culotte propres je ne crois pas je me
rappelle très bien de manuel valls ce
premier ministre français qui est allé à
munich et qui a fait des déclarations
critiquant devant la presse allemande la
politique ni gras noix venait à la verte
lc dont nul c'est pas du urban mais ça
n'était pas très loin mais néanmoins je
voudrais quand même dire une chose parce
que bon on est dont s'est félicité de la
fédéralisation du contrôle des
frontières extérieures
la question de la relocalisation c'est à
dire l'idée de contrer partie les
réfugiés qui sont arrivés pour que
chacun traite la demande d'asile pas
qu'ils accueillent pour l'éternité les
demandeurs d'asile simplement qu'ils
traitent les demandes d'asile 160 g
d'huile voilà cent soixante mille c'est
pas énorme par rapport aux millions je
crois que là on a été un pas trop loin
je crois qu'on a forcé la dose
parce que aujourd'hui le coeur de la
saudrais remonte même pas je crois
tellement ça marche ou ça ne marche pas
ce que c'est si les 6000 sur les 160
milles mais sauf que les nous lasser on
est on est correct tourneront vers
lequel les 4 me sur les 6 milles de là
dessus on joue plutôt le golf était
difficile paramore un pays sous les 106
millions d'habitants oui je dis pas que
c'est mais je sais pas ça fonctionne pas
bien
là je pense qu'on était un peu trop loin
parce que le coeur de la souveraineté
d'un état aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est
d'accueillir ou de ne pas accueillir des
étrangers sur son sol
c'est quelque chose et on le voit bien
les crispations identitaires qu'il y a
en grande bretagne c'est la grande
bretagne a voté c'est pourquoi c'est pas
à cause de l'europe en soit ce à cause
de la libre circulation dans laquelle on
mettait tous les européens et non
européens les réfugiés qui s'étaient
donc forcer un pays à accueillir contre
son gré même quelques centaines de
personnes
dans le cas de la hongrie saisissait pas
d'accueillir visage hideux en prendre la
soulager du nombre semble demandeurs
d'asile mais c'est le principe
et là je crois que on a voulu forcer la
marche vers le fédéralisme feu ce
contrôle ont d'abord nos frontières
extérieures ensuite si ça fonctionne je
pense que là ça créera de la confiance
est là on pourra parler de la
répartition et on a voulu un village us
d'accord avec une petite nuance mandat
natalie gray l'erreur c'est de faire des
quotas
et que ce soit la commission qui dès la
commission européenne qui décide des
quotas voilà il faut que les gens soient
capables d'exercer leurs responsabilités
étaient en vie et en sorte de
l'hypocrisie sorte de l'hypocrisie qui
consiste à dire une chose à bruxelles et
autre chose maintenant ce sont les deux
parties ont donné ce droit à la
commission européenne donc dans l'âme un
défaut plus de réalisme
il a membres ça ne nourrit pas donner un
jour me donnait dire à la commission
vous vous faites quelque chose on leur a
donné le droit de le faire
oui oui on leur a donné le droit il faut
trouver la corde et et or sur les souris
demandeurs d'asile et 5% se reconduit à
la frontière en france chez eux des
déboutés du droit d'asile ou fait
comment avec ses 95 % justement dublin
doit être complètement retravaillée pas
seulement sur les mineurs non
accompagnés excusez-moi dan d'insister
là dessus les démocraties que nous
sommes traités des enfants vulnérables
comme nous le faisons et spécialement
quelle france spécialement en prendre
c'est pas possible
mais sur les demandeurs d'asile on voit
bien que ça ça dysfonctionne il faut
avoir un système d'enregistrement adapté
et expliquer aussi exactement les textes
et donc peut-être pour ça les simplifier
et avoir une donc une politique qui soit
qui soit équilibrée ça va peut-être nous
réconcilier avec les valeurs européennes
direction l'allemagne berlin
comment les allemands accueillent leurs
réfugiés syriens souvent jeunes plus tôt
il y a les villes comme une classe e
tradiction des classes bienvenue des
classes pour aider des jeunes migrants à
s'intégrer à paris immense en période
d'austérité le reportage à berlin derib
el ameur
c'est quoi votre programme aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va apprendre l'allemand
et tu es là depuis quand je suis en
allemagne depuis huit mois
si jay ad mohamed ont réussi à apprendre
l'allemand si vite c'est grâce aux
villes comme une classe traduction des
classes bienvenue des classes pour rêver
les jeunes migrants à s'intégrer
situé à quelques kilomètres de berlin ce
lycée en compte deux huit élèves par
classe aujourd'hui au programme un
après-midi à berlin
à vervins il y à une de bus très célèbre
célèbre célèbre célèbre lignes de bus
une ligne de bus de la gare de band of à
travers la ville travers djeha de 14 ans
est venu seul de syrie c'est l'un des
nombreux mineurs isolés vivant en
allemagne
il a eu la chance d'avoir une place dans
l'internât du lycée privé d'école en
syrie il peut à nouveau à prendre et
surtout s'intégrer à son pays d'accueil
co et moi avons ouvert on a toujours
trois ou quatre heures d'allemand par
jour et après on a un peu de sport
nous on apprend surtout beaucoup
d'allemands et on travaille aussi à la
maison
or comme je vis dans un internat et que
je partage ma chambre avec un allemand
je parle toujours avec lui et j'ai
beaucoup d'amis ici
les allemands sont gentils mais ces
classes ne marche pas aussi bien pour
tout le monde arrive bien du kurdistan
il a 17 ans lui aussi appuyé la guerre
arrivé à berlin il intègre une classe
bienvenus mais après cinq mois de cours
aref a le sentiment de stagner dans la
classe c des petits enfants et je suis
le plus vieux je sais pas je n'apprends
pas grand chose ce n'est pas si bien mon
allemand je n'ai pas appris dans la
classe gelé a pris dehors avec mes amis
allemands pour les professeurs aussi le
défi est de taille
madame rosine est qu'à postuler dès
qu'elle a entendu parler du projet en
septembre 2015
elle fait donc sa deuxième rentrée en
classe bienvenus sans programme précis
face à des élèves souvent traumatisés de
nombreux professeurs krach des langues
se tasse j'ai entendu que beaucoup de
professeurs qui ont commencé en classe
bienvenue ont déjà démissionné en fin de
compte ça mélange un travail de
transmission de connaissances et de
travailleur social
de pédagogue de psychologues la plupart
du temps je suis plutôt une travailleuse
sociale
une professeure depuis l'ouverture des
classes d'intégration
une trentaine d'élèves ont bénéficié de
cet enseignement dans cette école trois
sont passés dans une classe général et
c'est l'heure des premiers bilans pour
la direction du lycée
je pense qu environ un tiers devrait
être capable d'intégrer le lycée général
et que les autres auront d'autres
parcours scolaire c'est quelque chose de
complètement différent d'entendre parler
d'un sujet aux informations de façon
abstraite et anonymes et d'avoir ahmed
mohamed de parler directement avec un
est d'entendre ce qu'ils ont vécu ça
c'est une expérience fondamentale pour
nos élèves et ça aide à considérer avec
plus de nuance le problème des réfugiés
en septembre 2015
berlin comme le reste de l'allemagne a
fait face à un afflux massif de réfugiés
et la région a choisi de les accueillir
à tout prix en un an
mille classes bienvenue ont été ouvertes
pour douze mille élèves en tout 1 par
immense alors que la ville a une dette
de 60 milliards d'euros est en pleine
cure d'austérité depuis des années nous
manquons de professeurs l'état des
bâtiments et très délabré nous manquons
d'école est en effet vu ce contexte
c'est vraiment remarquable qu'il y ait
cet accueil des efforts qui risque
d'être mise à mal sur la durée
système est au bord de la saturation et
surtout ces mesures coûtent très cher 64
millions d'euros par an
et je voulais vous poser cette question
ce que l'allemagne elle fait pas aussi à
un calcul qui va le lui profiter
j'accueille ces migrants la population
est vieillissante ça va permettre de
payer les retraites
disons qu'il y a qu il ya plusieurs
aspects qui joue un grand rôle l'aspect
de l'humanisme qui est bien là les
leçons que nous avons apprises avec le
grand nombre de citoyens d'origine
turque que nous avons que nous n'avons
pas toujours très bien intégré et donc
de savoir que l'intégration passe par la
connaissance de la langue et par la
connaissance de la langue aussi la
connaissance de la culture dans laquelle
on est mais aussi un aspect économique
c'est bien clair parce que la 6e dan la
société allemande est vieillissante nous
avons trop peu de deux nouveau-nés c'est
un problème que nous avons depuis des
dizaines d'années d'ailleurs en
allemagne donc là aussi nous nous disons
il serait bon si ces jeunes syriens qui
sont là reste chez nous et apportent
aussi leur contribution à l'économie
allemande nathalie griesbeck sur
l'intégration des migrants la france
elle reste à la traîne
oui selon un rapport de l' ocde mais
quand j'étais dans sur la route des
balkans à voir des choses qui
ressemblait des images de la de la
seconde guerre mondiale des images qu'on
voulait plus voir sur les voies de
chemin de fer à idaux mendy etc tous les
mails et toutes les personnes avec
lesquelles j'ai pu discuter voulait
aller comme elle disait en alemagna ou
en suède
je n'ai pas rencontré une seule un seul
réfugié souhaitant venir en france
d'accord pays soi-disant des droits de
l'homme il voulait aller en allemagne
parce qu'il semble que le refuge c'est
vraiment naze ils sont pas formés en
france que dit evelyne est très juste là
la réponse allemande c'est une réponse
globale humaniste et c'est l'histoire
aussi de l'allemagne s'est toujours en
toile de fond en filigrane l'histoire
même de l'allemagne
et moi je trouve que c'est vraiment
remarquable et nous nous avons nous nous
les français on est resté sur notre
quant à soi et c'est un échec jean
quatremer en france quand on vous dit
migrants vous avez craint
pour l'emploi angoisses sécuritaires sur
fond de terrorisme rejet dans les villes
sens et les accueillir
la numérisation du front national et
surtout fascination des médias pour pour
tout ce qui est négatif parce qu'on va
faire on va faire des sujets des unes de
journaux sur une magnifique
manifestation du front national contre
l'accueil d'un foyer de migrants
alors qu'en réalité quand on regarde
l'ensemble des chiffres c'est pas du
tout comme ça que réagi la population
française c'est exactement l'inversé en
très grande majorité les français sont
accueillants en très grande majorité ils
veulent accueillir des réfugiés ils
veulent jouer le jeu joué le jeu de
l'intégration il ya cinq sens pour
l'économie européenne a entendu parler
de la suède qui voit son taux de
croissance atteindre les 4,6 alors ce
sens et l'éducation c'est les migrants
écouter toutes les études économiques
sérieuses sur le passé et sur le futur
montrent que l'immigration c'est
évidemment une chance pour le pays qui
accueille des migrants
mais attention encore une fois une fois
qu'on a dit ça c'est des chiffres
économiques
mais il ya aussi le sentiment la
population ça doit être accompagnée et
en revient au problème français c'est
lorsque vous avez tous les mines tous
les deux tout les politiques qu'ils
soient de gauche ou de droite qui vous
explique que l'immigration est un
problème que les travailleurs détachés
polonais ou roumains sont un problème
en gros que tous les étrangers sont des
problèmes et encore une fois son
discours d'extrême droite ou d'extrême
gauche faut pas vous étonner qu en
france on ait des problèmes
d'intégration
oui mais parce que je peux rajouter
effectivement nous on représente ddd
peuple et on doit être en phase avec ce
que disent nos concitoyens et donc je
pense qu'il est très très important
qu'on puisse aussi répondre pas
seulement dans la compassion mais
juridiquement aux engagements qui sont
les nôtres plan européen en a qu en
accueillant les réfugiés c'est à dire
ceux qui bénéficient du droit
on sait que c'est une ancienne droguée
et
et selon moi de la précision les
migrants économiques qui sont en
difficulté mais qui sont pas dans la
même urgence et qui doivent être donc
conduit chez eux reconduits chez eux
quand ils sont en situation irrégulière
absolument
il faut bien distinguer entre les
réfugiés qui fuient la guerre et la
violence et qui doivent être accueillis
et dont on doit avec les médias expliqué
pourquoi face à des citoyens qui sont
souvent accueillant dans nos démocraties
et la situation migrants l'économique
est très importante c'est la fin
d'europe hebdo merci à vous trois
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi la
semaine prochaine vous retrouvez n'aura
hamadi à cette même place d'ici là bonne
suite des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
salut ciao au vu des résines